well hi everybody let's get started then
thank you so much for joining us today
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup
i'm rachel if i haven't had a chance to
meet you yet i'm calling in from boston
actually at the r studio office today
but if you just joined now feel free to
introduce yourselves to the chat window
and say hello
maybe where you're calling in from
[Music]
i like to let everybody know up front
you can use the more button in the zoom
bar below to turn on live transcription
if you wish
but just to go through a brief agenda
for today's meetup so happy to have you
all here we'll go through some short
introductions of the meetup group
and we'll have birla here presenting on
her experience optimizing shiny for
enterprise grade apps
and we'll also have lots of time for
questions
verily said we can also ask questions
during the middle of the presentation
too but we'll have lots of time at the
end as well
um so for anybody who's joining this
group for the first time
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment and i'm sure everybody's
heard this feel a bunch before
but for teams to share the work they're
doing within their organizations teach
lessons learn
network with each other
and really just allow us all to learn
from each other so thank you all for
making this a welcoming community
we really want to create a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
i always love to reiterate
that we really love to hear from
everyone no matter your experience or
the industry that you worked in as well
just a quick reminder that this session
will be recorded
and shared to youtube for anyone who
missed it or if you want to go back and
check it out again
so for questions
you can also use the slido link which
i'll put in the chat in just a moment
so with that you can ask questions
anonymously too if you don't want to be
part of the recording
um or you can put your name there and we
can call on you to jump in the
conversation which is always fun too
but with all of that thank you all so
much for joining
i'm so excited to turn it over to you
virila
and i will
mute myself here and turn it over to you
okay
hi welcome everybody nice to see you all
i'm just closing down this presentation
and
move on to mine
one second
all right good to see you all um today
we're going to talk about optimizing
shiny for enterprise great applications
and what that exactly will be um i will
tell you all about it in a couple of
minutes
um
so
what are we going to talk about today
so first i'll give a little bit of an
introduction so that you know who's
talking to you
also a bit about the companies that you
have a little bit of background on the
kind of applications that we're making
then i'm going to
dig into the content and we'll start
with what happens before you start
coding then we're going to the coding
part so how do you write code for an
enterprise great application um then
we'll talk about infrastructure
some tips and tricks on how to optimize
shiny then we go over how to test your
application and the last part will be
about monitoring your status of the
application and usage
so first i'll start by introducing um
myself
um my name is ferde i'm a data scientist
i graduated as a data scientist in 2015
already in the netherlands
that's also where i'm calling in from
today i did a masters of data science
and after that i started working as a
data scientist at
some companies started off with an
energy company then ended up in the
pharmaceutical industry at dr reddy's
and at a certain point in time i was
like i want to start my own business i
have so many ideas and i want to do
things my own way so i find it founded
hybrid which was data science
consultancy firm and during um all my
nice assignments there i met my current
business partner greg mills with who i
now run analytic health and i'm managing
director and head of data science there
i'm an r programmer i love programming r
i build shiny applications and besides
that i'm also doing a bit of javascript
building applications in view
and node
so a bit more a bit more
background about the company analytic
health who are we
at analytic health we develop tools and
applications for the uk healthcare
sector we try to accelerate innovation
in healthcare by giving companies the
tools they need to access data and to
get information from the data and in
order to do that we have two
applications the first one is pharmacy
analytics and the second one is farm the
cloud data formula link is a shiny
application as well as farming cloud
data
and uh with farming cloud data we are
also
giving access to a plumber api so we do
lots of stuff in art we already record
team of three people it's myself my
business partner greg mills and our head
of operation gianna
and um
to to start
talking about enterprise great apps i
want to take you into what that exactly
is
because an enterprise great app can mean
many things for many of us and most of
the people
who hear enterprise great think about oh
this is an app serving thousands and
thousands of users with
lots of servers behind it they think big
um and while that might be true for an
enterprise great app it's not the only
thing that defines an enterprise great
app so this is my view on what it
actually means
and what it means to us
so for example the applications that we
are giving access to are subscription
based and they are for the b2b market
that means that people
pay for them it's not an open source app
which also means that if obviously you
are offering your app through
subscriptions that you need to have some
kind of access control and extra data
security um sometimes people or
companies also provide their own data to
us which means that we need to have a
high level of data security
and
because people and businesses rely upon
our applications to make decisions on a
daily basis we need to have high
availability speed and there needs to be
data validation so the data that we're
using is
healthcare data from the uk
that can mean that we have information
about
the prescriptions that have been written
what
prices are of medicines what the
clearance shortages are in the uk etc
and obviously if you have this
information this information needs to be
correct so there are high data
validation demands
on top of that what i think
distinguishes like a hobby shiny app
from an enterprise great app is an
outstanding user experience which means
that you need to put in considerable
thought on how the app behaves what it
looks like and what the overall feeling
is of the application
and an extra thing that comes with an
enterprise break app is support meaning
that if people have questions um they
can come to you immediately and that you
provide this high level of support for
your application
so again enterprise grade in my opinion
has nothing to do with the number of
users can be thousands of users can be
tens of users can be 5100 it doesn't
really matter um what qualifies for me
as an enterprise great app is that you
put in considerable thoughts on the
availability on the app and the
experience when people are using your
application
and in fact i also want to say that an
enterprise
shiny app shouldn't actually feel as a
shiny ad we sometimes get that comment
from people who are seeing our app for
the first time and our shining
developers they say oh this doesn't look
like a shiny app but
like i love shiny and i'm i'm here to
promote china definitely um but people
shouldn't see with what software the app
was made it needs to look like a good
app good functioning app high quality um
so i see that as a complement so the
software behind it shouldn't really
matter
um it's the outcome that matters in this
case
so today i'm giving you kind of a sneak
peek on how we manage things and as i
said we have two applications and i will
take
you along with one of our applications
which is farmly cloud data i will during
my presentation reference this app a
couple of times um
to just give you examples on how we do
things with this certain app and how it
works and what the infrastructure is etc
so a bit more background about the
application the application is kind of
the data marketplace for the uk
you go into the app you choose the data
set that you're interested in you search
for your active ingredients or for your
medicine brands that you're looking
after and you can download that data
it's not a complicated app meaning that
there are not uh machine learning models
happening or that there are not
complicated graphs or something but um
the app is all about giving you an easy
user interface to access all the data
that you need to make your decisions
then there are a couple of nice features
there like you can add your own
favorites and you can monitor your usage
of the app
because behind this app is in plumber
api
and the plumber api
and our subscription-based model works
with the number of requests meaning that
people have a plan
a subscription plan and that kind of
determines how many requests they can
make so in the web interface they can
also see how many requests they already
have made
and how many they are still left in the
month
um and you can fully customize the
outcome of the data set meaning that you
can change column orders that you can
change settings the number of months you
want to retrieve etc etc
and you simply download that to an excel
file
so that's a bit of background of the app
that i will be referencing a couple of
times today
so
let's um first start not by going into
the code immediately
but first with a very important and
overlooked theme
the ui first principle or user
experience and use experience
because
one does not simply succeed without a
plan um and often
especially if there are a lot of data
scientists here today we think whoa i
need to build an application um let's
code but what we often forget is that we
first need to think very carefully about
what the app is being used for how
people are going to use it what it needs
to look like where the buttons need to
be etc and this
is often an overlooked part of building
an application especially
if you're coming from an analyst
background data scientist or whatsoever
um and this is not only true for a shiny
application by the way but for any
application you develop so put some
considerable thought into
how the application is going to work
um
we kind of
going back to my own experience at the
beginning we were also exactly like that
okay we need to build this feature we're
going to build it immediately went into
the code um
well that does lead to problems because
as soon as you are going to deploy your
application then your users start seeing
the feature then it's like oh yeah maybe
it wasn't working out as we thought in
the beginning so these are all things
you want to know up front
and ux designers can help you with that
perfectly because they exactly know how
how things should work and then you can
see it before you actually start
and obviously there are shiny ways to
make this kind of a prototype
and one shiny way i want to highlight is
the shiny ipsum package
with the shiny apps and backwards you
can make this prototype in shiny
yourself and while this does mean that
you start kind of with the code it is a
bit different because here you can put
in placeholders in your user interface
meaning that you can very easily set up
an app and just say okay i want to have
here a table or a plot and some text an
a button and then you can kind of play
it around with the user interface first
before you actually start writing the
server code
so obviously the shiny ibsen package
makes a reference to the
lorem ipsum dummy text um
it's very easy to use and
i would definitely recommend it um if
you're looking for a quick way to
prototype your applications
so
once you've done that you've kind of
know what your app is going to be about
what it's going to look like what it
should do um you go into the code
and that's the interesting part
but to build enterprise great
applications you also need to put in
some considerable thought into how
you're going to manage that code and how
um you're going to build your
application to scale it and
this is something that we have learned
over the years as well
we're a startup company we basically
started with an app and then that grew
and built and more customers came on it
so
we learned over the years that it's very
important to if you have this massive
app that can do a lot of stuff and that
grows over time that your code is
maintainable um
and that you can work with it
so how do you exactly make maintainable
code because that's kind of a magic
thing um
these are principles that are
well not necessarily for shiny but for
any app that you're developing in any
software
it's important that you write code which
is easy to understand and debug
meaning that you think about coding
style commenting your code keep it
stupid simple
the kiss principle
so that is always easy to understand you
can choose to write really complex code
but that honestly never helped us
because
if you developed something very complex
with a very complex piece of code and
then look at it a couple of months later
you're like ah
i don't know what was actually happening
here some magic
and it does give me the desired outcome
but you have no clue
what's actually going on there anymore
so keep it simple
we're also
talking about maintainable code we're
looking for an easy to modify and
enhance code meaning that don't repeat
yourself or dry principle
meaning that if you need to make a
change to your code because let's say in
our app we're going to add another data
set
then obviously we don't want to do
everything again we don't want to repeat
our code if we need to make changes need
to have a fast because we want to have
new features out fast
so build your code
like that you can easily modify it
i'm going to talk a bit more about it
later on and what you can actually use
and what we use to kind of don't repeat
ourselves
also separation is key
i remember when i started working as
data scientist at dr reddy's and had to
build my first shiny app and i was super
proud of the app because it had like i
don't know 3 000 lines of code in one
script which was f.r and i was like whoa
this is a really cool app so many lines
of code um
honestly i didn't know what i knew now
obviously um because separation
splitting your code up into small
easily consumable parts is essential
that app that i built
in the early days um three thousand
lines of code not maintainable at all if
i needed to find something
it could take me minutes or maybe half
an hour to actually search through code
and
make it all work so
what we do now at analytic health is we
separate basically every separate piece
of functionality into separate scripts
so that if um also in separate
directories meaning that if we need to
find something or a specific piece that
does this or that that we can easily
find it
um also we need to have code that's easy
to test um and there comes the automated
units tests in place um if you
have separated your code in like these
terms it's also easier to test only that
script for the desired outcome
um and i'll also talk a little bit more
about that later when i'm talking about
how to functionalize your code
all right
so maintainable code that's one thing um
then how are you going to organize your
shiny app um and how are we doing that
we have one way you can do it is golem
and almighty modules um
everybody talks about modules especially
when you are talking about building
enterprise apps or building apps for
production or as soon as you come into
the territory of more advanced shiny
apps then there's no way to go around
modules and
golem is a package that based golem is a
package that actually helps you to build
your shiny application as a package
so golem is basically a framework for
building your production great shiny
application it helps you to structure
your code and to organize it and to
basically be able to make your shiny app
as an r package if you have any
experience with building our packages it
seems very familiar to you
because all the
other things that you're used to of
making functions in your package are
also here as well so it's super easy to
document super easy to test so coming
back to how to build maintainable code
make sure that you can test it
go and kind of facilitate that and
obviously because if you can package it
you can also easily share it so that's
also a great advantage
and it makes use of shiny modules
so
you hear a lot about modules
but there's also another way that you
can kind of manage or make maintainable
code
and that is functionizing i don't know
if this is an actual word
but what i mean with functionizing your
r code is basically that you build your
code up as functions and this helps you
to
don't repeat yourself because if you're
making functions out of
several server scripts or ui parts
then you can easily
use those functions in other parts of
the application so
coming back to my app um from cloud data
or our app i should say sorry
um pharmacloud data um
we what we do there is we provide access
to different data sets so let's say we
have 10 data sets and for those 10 data
sets you can kind of request active
ingredients and brands and then you can
download data every tab that's in that
app does look kind of the same so what
we did here instead of using modules for
a variety of reasons we
chose to functionalize
the code
meaning that if we now need to make an
adjustment to let's say the download
button um we can very easily do so by
just changing that function and
functions are
a fundamental unit of abstraction in r
we use functions all the time
r is built around functions
um so it's very helpful to do that at
least like that and to help you to
make your apps scalable
so what functions don't do is address
the name spacing problem because that is
what modules do so when you're using
functions you still need to make sure
yourself that none of the input and
output names or ids
have a conflict with each other because
in a shiny app you can't use the same
ids for inputs or the same ids for
outputs because then it will just not
work
so that is one downside of using
functions and um
yeah as i said you can use modules
because they add this one
extra level of abstraction and taking
care of the namespace problem
but functions will already get you
well good
as a good start
then another thing uh another framework
that i want to highlight today and if
you uh know me already then you might
have seen this
but it's about a new package rhino
right now is developed by epsilon and
it's also a framework
that kind of promises to
help you build enterprise level shiny
applications so it kind of
is similar to golem but something
different what rhino does i think it was
only released a couple of weeks ago what
rhino does is it helps you to have this
kind of framework around building your
shiny app and helping you with all kinds
of best practices and giving you
development tools so it provides you
with the basic structure of a project it
provides you with a folder structure um
files kind of the same as when you're
using golem and it also provides tools
to work with javascript and sas for
example
so this one uses box to modulize code
meaning
what box does
box basically makes our files
importable as kind of modules
meaning that you can just write an r
script and then can import it using box
and then it works kind of the same as a
module so it's a bit different than
shiny models work
and it's definitely an interesting
concept
so it's actually also a little bit
similar to um
uh chopping up like your big app.r
script into multiple uh r scripts and
then importing them in another way box
kind of take care of that in a more
clever way so that you don't repeat
yourself
definitely where to look
um
the other thing
now
is okay you've built your code you have
nice
nice code nicely structured it's
maintainable you have built your um
yeah your kind of structure of your app
using either golem functions
rhino whatever there is
then this obvious question how are you
going to bring that to your users you're
going to use it so a little bit about
infrastructure and how we do that um
obviously there are thousands of ways
you can
do it i'm not saying that
the way we did it is like the
the most ultimate way to do it
but for us it works very well
um so these are my experiences and our
setup
um
and this is our infrastructure so i've
kind of simplified it it here than how
it is in the real world obviously but
our broad infrastructure looking beyond
shiny looks like this
like first we get our data somewhere and
we get data from the nhs the national
health service in the uk
then we do some stuff in r to transform
it clean it validate it et cetera then
we send it somewhere to be stored and we
use pins and databases for that
if you're not familiar with bins would
definitely read up about it it's just a
nice way to store any uh our objects
um
once we have our data somewhere then we
build tools around the data as i said we
have apis uh using plumber we have shiny
applications but we also do our markdown
reports and evo reports
using blastula and then we deploy it and
we use rstudio connect for that
so our apis and our shiny apps are
deployed on our studio connect and are
accessed from our customers outside of
organization you don't hear that a lot
with our studio connect people actually
do that
but you can really nicely do that
because you can also add your own
branding to connect meaning
that it's also perfectly usable for
outside customers if they want to access
your application in a safe way because
as i said that's important for us that
there is some access control so kind of
a login mechanism and our studio connect
really takes care of that very well
so then we basically have our etl our
extract transform load and we have our
apps we have it deployed and then
obviously around that is monitoring we
need to make sure that every step of the
process is being taken care of version
control meaning
that we need to have for example our api
um customers are directly able to access
data via the api and can use the api in
their own pipelines dashboards databases
etc so it's very important to have a
version control on there because if you
release a new version and have breaking
changes what if the pipeline of the
customer depends on that so there's this
whole version and control system
around our infrastructure
and then we also have a logging part
which i'm not going to go into detail
about but we just make sure that we know
what's happening in every step
of this process
and then if we zoom in a bit more to
our infrastructure when it comes to our
applications on connect
we have a shiny app which i showed you
farming cloud data and actually
the server part of the shiny app is not
that interesting because what the shiny
app does is it's making requests to the
plumber api so basically our backend is
being written as an api in plumber
this is not any different from for
example writing a few applications or
applications in javascript because there
you often have front-end and back-end
completely separated shiny brings them
together
but
in this case we kind of chose to
also separate it here so we have an api
that fetches the data from a database in
our case databases in azure
and the plumber api
then does some processing to retrieve
the correct data whatever was requested
and sends it back to the application
the application
um
server part is then only about okay make
a request and we're done with it the
other thing that the shiny application
does is making uh use of pins so as i
briefly mentioned pins are a way where
you can store your r objects it's
basically you could kind of compare it
to a database it's not the same but it's
a place where you store
r-related stuff
for example data tables
models uh objects
whatever you want really you can pin it
and then you can use these pins um to
kind of source your data into your
application
so the shiny app
the only thing that's in the server part
is actually making requests to another
app or another api making requests to
fetch some data for example what needs
to be displayed in the pickers so what
are the choices which active ingredients
can people select which brands can
people select etc
and the most of the shiny the code is
actually the front end and that's all
being functionized so basically we have
like a couple of things just for our
whole user interface that provides kind
of 10 tabs for 10 data sets and a
dashboard and a favorite step
um etc
so it is deployed on rstudio connect um
we only have uh one server available
that kind of serves our studio connect
it's a it's a good
server and fits our needs obviously if
you have a very large audience of let's
say thousands of users
you might want to look into
putting multiple servers
and then kind of load balancing across
these servers uh which rco connect is
also capable of we just have one and
what we kind of do
to make sure that our apps are
accessible and fast is we have always a
couple of our processes running at
minimum to serve these apps um for
example for the plumber api we have five
processors always running and for the
shiny app also five meaning that there
are ten processes are processes always
running to server applications so that
people quickly can access the
application and do whatever they want
there
um i will come back to that a little bit
about
this process configuration and how these
minimum number of processes work
but this is kind of our
base infrastructure if i really simplify
it
and i can also give you that as the
biggest
tip
we've seen a lot of benefits which using
an api plumber api instead of doing
everything in that one session
in in the shiny application itself so
kind of we separated it that makes it
one more maintainable and two faster as
well because we can kind of spread our
load between what the app is doing on
the front end versus what is happening
in the back end and we can also do those
things in parallel
as i said this is just one way how we do
it there are obviously a bunch of
alternatives um
not going into too much detail about it
but just um so you know there are
multiple solutions to to achieve
um
deployment of your application for for
an enterprise and
one thing that you can do
if your app grows bigger and has more
traffic you can add load balancing and
high availability using our studio
connect meaning that you kind of
configure rcu connect to be across
multiple servers
um
and then setting up an external shared
file server
that kind of then serves as the
where all the files are stored for
studio connect
and then you have a lot of solutions
with docker obviously um
what kind of our studio connect does
under the hood docker
is something that you can do separately
to kind of ship your application with
this environment to a server um whatever
server that may be and then your app is
being run there
and
azure can be used for that as your app
service but also any other cloud service
provider really has these these options
do that and then there's also shiny
server open source which is a fully open
source solution where you can also
[Music]
which you can add to one of your servers
if you want and search your application
from there so there are lots of
alternatives and i can talk for hours
about um how how you can set that up and
how you can do that and
going into the technicalities uh but
this is just to give you a brief
overview of um what options there are
and that um
our studio connect is one of them
so
um we've opted my uh
we did not optimize shine yet but we
have deployed our application somewhere
so we've written our code um we've made
it uh maintainable we have uh build a
structure um we have thought about user
experience so we've deployed it
somewhere so
now it's a time to go look into a bit
more detail into how we can optimize
shiny to kind of make sure that
everybody who wants to access the
application at the given point in time
can also do so
and the first thing i'm going to talk
about
with you is a process configuration and
i quickly touched upon this when i said
that we always have
five r processors running for our shiny
app for our plumber api
because as you might know a shiny app or
a plumber api requires an r process
meaning that r needs to be up and
running and that needs to be ready to do
stuff
you can configure
these kind of settings and these kind of
settings that i mentioned here
maximum processes minimum processes
maximum connections per process
load factor
you can set them in in most cases
yourself so in shiny apps dot io which
is not an enterprise solution but if
you're still there
these settings will also be there in
rstudio connect um
and it's just very important also for
uh if you are deploying your app in uh
for any other cloud service provider
it's important to understand how this
works and how you are kind of
redirecting your users to
an our process
because the shiny app requires in our
process okay so then there is another
process in the shiny app and then there
is also a user
so a user can basically hop on to that r
process and you can say okay i want to
have only one user for our process or i
want to have multiple and that is kind
of going to determine your scalability
of your application
so
things that you can tweak for example
are the maximum number of processes that
you are allowing to
run for your shiny app if you set it
very high let's say the maximum number
of process can be 40 i don't know
50 000 whatever you choose um it also
means that it's more resource consuming
because the more uh our processes you
have running on your server the more
that server is going to be occupied with
actually maintaining and managing all
those r processes so
you need to be a bit considerate here
about okay
how many processes do i really need
and
am i potentially overloading my server
the minimum number of processes is
means you have as in our case a minimum
number of processes running for your
shiny app at any point in time
so
if you set this higher let's say 10 15
50
it means that you also consume more
resources because all these processes
are running they consume
memory of your server so the higher you
set this the more reason consuming it
will be so you need to think about that
in our case we chose for five minimum
processes because
if we're looking at the number of users
that are coming at the simultaneous time
to the app and are doing stuff this is
more than enough
but
if you have the minimum number of
processes
set it means that there's always an r
process running for your application
meaning that the startup in time will
increase drastically because
and that's kind of the downside of
building a shiny app
the r process needs to be startup
so besides loading your app
it also needs to load in our session so
together that can take a lot of time and
people don't like to wait and especially
if you are building
apps for for a larger audience apps that
people pay for
and you have to have high expectations
people can't wait uh 40 seconds for that
app to load needs to be 10 seconds max
and if there's any loading time at all
then it needs to be um some kind of
user-friendly way of loading with kind
of spinners and waiters and and whatever
um but this is really important for us
to make sure that our app is fast um
also when it's starting up
then you have the maximum connections
per process which means how many users
are you letting on to each our process
if you set this very low um it means
that for example in our case we have set
it to one
um there's only one user allowed per
process because otherwise
users have to wait for each other
because if one user is pushing a button
to do a calculation then the other then
the session is basically occupied and we
all know when our session is occupied
then yeah you can um
you kind of can give an assignment or a
calculation but r won't do anything
until the previous one is executed
so um
we've chosen to set our maximum
connection per session per process to
one
but it really depends on how your app is
working and um what is best for you
but the lower you set it and the less
load there will be per process but it
will also be more resist consuming so we
constantly see here already the kind of
the
decision you need to make between how
many resources do i want to invest
versus how
dedicated do i want my processes to be
the last one is load factor uh that's a
value between zero and one and uh the
lower means um that you spin up many new
processes so you can also if you have
uh the maximum number of connections
proposed to set to five for example five
users can simultaneously access your r
session
if you set it very low it means that as
soon as these people start hitting
buttons and doing calculations and
asking things from the r session that
they get redirected to another process
or that the new process is being spun up
to kind of handle that load
in our case it doesn't matter because we
only have one connection per session
but it could mean a lot
like playing around with these settings
can
drastically change the performance of
your app
i remember from previous apps that i
deployed
using either i think it was even called
rstudio shiny server or something like
that back in the days
but
you can see changes pretty soon when you
are playing around with these settings
so keep that in mind
so that's one thing that you can
optimize
but most of the game really is to be
made in the app itself so how are you
going to make your app fast how good are
you going to make your app enjoyable um
because that is part of building
enterprise great apps they need to work
great people expect a lot from them
so
smart coding um
how are we going to speed up our shiny
application one way we can do that is by
using cache and cash is an interesting
way
of kind of reducing the time it takes to
get output
so
imagine that people can hit a button in
your shiny app and once they hit that
button
there will be a very lengthy calculation
running um i don't know maybe you have
some kind of machine learning model or
or something
but they choose
one input and the calculation runs and
it gets an output it's obviously a shame
if then a second user comes in chooses
the exact same input does the
calculation again and gets the exact
same output again it's kind of a waste
of time why should you do that
calculation twice
so this is where cash comes in because
what you also can do is say okay well
the first user um
requested a result for this input input
a we call it
um we do that lengthy calculation yes it
takes some time but for the next ones
the next users we're not going to do
that no instead we're going to
immediately use the results that were
being cashed from that calculation so
cash is basically a way of storing your
output
somewhere
in this case on your server or whatever
you choose to store it
and then retrieving it from storage
instead of doing the calculation so
especially if you have a large audience
for your app it can save a lot of time
and especially if the large audience is
doing many of the same things
and not only if you have a large
audience there um even if you have just
one user using your app but it's
constantly switching between input a b c
a b c uh b again c again it's kind of
requesting constantly that same
calculation
because he's just shifting inputs and he
forgets kind of what the outcome of a
was so goes back again and so even for
single users um it can be very
beneficial to just store these results
um there are two ways uh you can
implement cache in shiny the first is
the memoirs package
which kind of
helps you to store functions
and the result of those functions as
cash and you have chinese bind cash
function
um
i have an example of both of them on my
git page and i will share
that afterwards
so
cash sounds nice but a couple of
disclaimers um it's obviously only
useful when your output does not change
um and does not change often
so
let's say that your output changes uh i
don't know because there's a random seat
in there or whatever it changes every
time that there's no point it also is
not that much point if your data behind
it changes like every i don't know six
hours
or every day it only is useful when it
doesn't change regularly so that it's
actually a point of storing your output
um
then the downside of using cache is that
it requires space because obviously
output needs to be stored somewhere and
that requires some space
and
you need to think about sensitive data
as well because if you are kind of
sharing your cached results with your
other users
you need to think about okay is user a
allowed to see
whatever user c did you know is that
output for them the same is that um
something that they both should be able
to access so that's something
that you need to think about but cash
can be a game changer in the performance
of your app
another smart thing you can do is using
background processes and i touched upon
it a bit by saying that if you have
multiple users per connection that they
have to wait for each other because the
session is occupied
well that sometimes can happen and we
don't want that because we don't want to
have parallel execution now we want to
have a synchronous execution of code
especially if you're developing an app
from multiple users you want to then to
be able to do things at the same time
and not be affected and in fact
you also don't want a user to have to
wait
while something is being calculated and
that he or she cannot do anything in the
app so
let's say a user hits a button to kind
of render a graph and then
in the background some data is being
retrieved from the database
and then calculations are being done and
then the graphs being rendered well
maybe the user doesn't want to wait
those i don't know 30 seconds to for the
graph to show up but maybe in between
the user wants to look at another table
and maybe hit another button for a
lighter calculation or another
calculation um you don't want people to
wait
so
this is where color comes into play into
play because with calling you can spin a
background art processes and this is
really cool because your shiny app is
running on one r process and then you
can use the color to kind of set up an
additional r process
do the calculations there
then fetch the result and put it back
into the current our process so this is
especially useful if you have queries to
databases which take a very long time
and this is actually the exact same
thing that we do with our api in fact
and our shiny app because
we actually let an other our process the
work do
do the work
retrieve the data from the database
and then kind of send the results back
um
that's a similar principle to caller
only here you do it in the shiny app
um at the same time and this is also
useful for example uh when you are
starting up your application so on
startup most often a bunch of data has
to be loaded and you want to
display graphs and tables and whatever
it might be useful if you just say okay
i'll just give a little boost and on
startup i'll spin up multiple processes
for my application
and it works really nice color um shuts
itself down when the process is done and
it's just a really nice and clean way to
kind of
put some extra resources to your shiny
app
then another
thing
about the api um
how you can see that because as i said
our app is about retrieving data from
the api displaying it and making it
available to download
so in our case it means the faster our
api is the faster our shiny app is
because
even though we are pulling in i don't
know 100 000 lines of data whenever
somebody makes a request we want to
happen that to happen in split seconds
um what we want to avoid is people have
to wait even 10 seconds for that data
because one of our selling points of our
app is it's super fast so for us it's
very important that the api is fast so
the shiny app can be false
and
one of the real game changes for our app
and our api was is that we
were going to use feather instead of
json like a plumber api
by default
returns json but you can also let it
default to other data formats
for example feather and we found that
feather is almost two point times
two and a half times faster in
comparison to json and also the file
size is being reduced because we have to
send data from the api to the app um the
more data we have to send in terms of
size the longer it's going to take so
by implementing feather and
sending it over as a smaller feather
file um it was very
it took uh it saved a lot of time to
actually send that feather file instead
of a json file
and in some cases we were actually able
to reduce api response time by as much
as 50
and
those are massive numbers um we're very
happy that that we've used feather and
you can use feather in any situation um
so let's say that you are reading in
reading in a file from disk for example
try to convert it to a feather file and
then read it in as a feather file and
most often you are way faster even with
even faster than like functions like f3
for reading a csv and whatever um
this is a really cool
way to speed up
your
shiny application
all right um so i hope these kind of
tips helped you to kind of um have some
ideas about how you can improve your
shiny application and how you can
make your app faster and how we did it
um
so this was kind of the stuff that i
wanted to talk about when it comes to
coding um
now i want to talk a bit about testing
um because it's obviously very important
that if you have an app for
um like users enterprise users customers
who are relying uh on a daily basis on
the information that you have in the
application
you obviously want to test it
you want to test to make sure that it
can handle uh the load that you're
giving it
and you want to be able to test um
if it's working as expecting anyway so
does your app every morning do you know
if it's running or do you have to check
yourself how
can you be sure that at any point in
time your app does what it is supposed
to do
so first we're going to take a look at
the first question i asked um is your
app
ready for the load that it's supposed to
handle
so we need to test for load
and testing for load we can do with a
package called shiny load test and shiny
load test provides the command line tool
called shiny canon and because i find
find shiny canon a lot cooler than shiny
load test i put that as the as the
headline um
and this basically can answer the
question for you how many users can your
shiny app support
and
it's really cool because the only thing
that you need to do is record your r
session like you're a normal user
and then you kind of
let shiny load test simulate all those
recordings and replay them in parallel
meaning that it can kind of
simulate the situation in which multiple
users at the same time are going to
access your app
and then after that you can analyze the
results
shiny load test has a bunch of
convenient functions in there that allow
you to
analyze all the files that it generates
and then you can build nice looking
reports and these reports can for
example tell you the time it takes to
load the html home page or the time it
takes to take
to grab your css or javascript files or
uh the starting time of the session so
how long it actually takes before shiny
uh connects uh to stock.js
um also calculation time of for example
any button that you press or any graph
that you try to render or table that
you're going to display
and you also get uh yeah a lot of
details about individual events um
and and a bunch of information is here
and this makes sure that you know
okay my app can safely handle this load
and then you need to see okay does it
actually fit my expectation of how many
people are going to visit the app or do
i need to change something
it's also great to find out what is
taking the most time and where you can
get some efficiency gains
so we test for load
another thing that we want to test is
test for outcome and testing for outcome
means that we want to be sure that when
somebody pushes a button um that the
outcome is what we expected and we can
test for outcome with the package called
shiny test2 it's actually the follow up
of the package called shiny test no
surprises there
um and
this package you can use to create and
run automated tests and behind the hood
it uses test that so what you kind of do
here in this package is also you record
just like shiny low test you record the
session
and then you kind of replay it
but in this case shiny test two will
translate your actions into actual code
that's really cool it's like magic but
it will write actual actual unit tests
for you using test that um so this
allows you then to
kind of everybody talks about our unit
stats are a pain and they take a lot of
effort there's so much time and i don't
have time to write them and always
forget it this makes it super easy um
i mean it doesn't get easier than that
you just
play around in the app you click a few
things and the code is there for you
um this package uses chrome mode to uh
launch a chrome browser
a headless one um
and it's um
a really cool way to
kind of make sure that your app is doing
what it's supposed to do plus what the
thing that's up to you and it's your
responsibility
is you need to update those tests
whenever you are making a deployment or
or whatsoever if you don't update your
tests um then it's pretty useless
but it's a nice way to be confident
about releasing your application with a
new update because unfortunately when
you change and we all know that when you
change somewhere
in one part of the app another thing
might break and this kind of prevents
that so this is really key
to make sure that you don't ship
anything to production
before it's really good
so um i'm moving on to the last part i
want to tell you something about
how to monitor app performance and app
usage because
um we've walked through the whole
pipeline now from like designing ux
designing to code to optimizing shiny to
deploying it
to testing your application
like very high level
but then there's also the thing about
okay how are you going to monitor your
app and how are you going to know how
many people are actually using your app
and how we do that so how we do that is
with uh something i'm still very proud
of every day um our status reports we
have created status reports uh with
blastula and our studio connect meaning
that every morning
or whenever we wish
we get a status report in our mailbox
like this looking like this um i even
check in on my phone it's like awesome
and it just tells me exactly okay this
is all good or this is not good or pay
attention to this these apps are running
these urls are accessible this is the
status of our services um
and while there's a bunch of stuff here
that isn't necessarily related to shiny
but more about our servers it is
important for us to know our server is
up and running um because our apps run
on those servers
and
we we want to make sure that like every
morning everything is running as
intended so what we kind of do
every day is we check uh the disk space
because unfortunately it happened once
to us and
i'm sure i'm not the only one that the
disk space was used 100 and what happens
then yeah then your server won't won't
do anything anymore so your app
is not working so that's not cool um
also things like is the engine's
configuration on
are the urls accessible and stuff like
that it's a great way to kind of monitor
what's going on into your pipeline into
your infrastructure um
and it's just nice to get it as an email
so that you are always up to date
and
i want to go back to shiny canon because
shiny canon is not only useful for
building these load tests and kind of
see how many users your shiny app can
support but it's also a great way to
kind of
check if your app is still behaving the
same as yesterday
because with shiny cannon or shiny load
test you recorded something a recording
of you kind of replaying the app and
with the command line tool
so shiny canon you can run this as a
single recording so you can use shiny
canon to do these load tests with the
number of workers and the load duration
and kind of simulating 50 users at the
same time but you can also use it to say
okay i have a recording here play it
and then give me the results and is it
the same as expected then yes thumbs up
um if not um give a warning in our case
in one of our state's reports so this is
also a great way to kind of
automatically check if your app is
actually running and doing what it is
supposed to do
and then a little bit about usage um you
need to make sure um if you're if you're
building your application for your
customers you need to make sure if
they're actually using it and how much
what we did obviously a very shiny way
to do that we built our own app which we
called the console app
and in the console that we can do a
bunch of things and one of those things
is checking usage of our apps meaning
that we can see how many times people
logged in who did log in
how long whether they're for
what did they do
etc
this allows us to build us a better
product but it also allows us to
kind of check in with customers like is
everything so okay can i help you with
something um that kind of stuff
so um
like even though we're a startup we
invested uh a good amount of time into
building these kind of tools because
it's very important for us to have
insight into usage and insight into
what's happening like in our daily
operations
and then a very quick note about that
you can also do this with rc connect
we'll be very familiar to rachel i think
um
you can use the api from our studio
connect if you're using connect to
deploy your apps and you can get all
these kinds of stats as well um super
easy to see who did log in who interacts
with your content which content is being
viewed most um at which times of the day
and um
in which weeks etc so um very important
if you're
building apps for
uh an enterprise level
and then i want to have a closing note
with um can you build enterprise great
apps with shiny uh yes you definitely
can
and i hope that um today i showed you a
little bit of how we manage things and i
hope i gave you some tips and tricks to
make enterprise great apps or to
optimize your existing apps or just
um
learn new some some general stuff about
shiny
i don't know now it's time for questions
amazing i think there are there are some
there are lots of questions thank you so
much bayla i always like to say we're
all clapping if you can't hear us we can
use our emojis here
um thank you thank you
i will thank you all so much for the
great questions too
i see there's one that was upvoted that
is what's the benefit of using pins
rather than pulling the data from your
database in azure
well what we sometimes found is that
pins are actually quicker than doing it
in our database so
we use pins to kind of store information
that's subseted
and
while
you obviously can retrieve substituted
information from your database a
database needs to run a query needs to
find the correct subset can take a
couple of seconds and if the pin already
contains all the information you need
pre-processed
whatever
it's much quicker to do that
uh besides that um the the data comes in
the correct format already so whether
you stored it with like um
as a data table or as a table and with
kind of the column formatting you want
so this column needs to be an eye date
or this column needs to be checked or
whatever that's all preserved so it's
like a really clean way to
in an r way
quickly retrieve information and it
obviously only does work for
subset or processed data
but we found that's very very beneficial
awesome thank you um and just a quick
note i'm not going to allow people to
unmute today and ask questions which
really stinks i love to be able to have
you all ask your own questions i just
don't trust it right now
so
if you do want to ask questions you can
use the slido
and so it's just
i'll put the link in the chat or
jacqueline or lauren if you can share
but it's just r s t d dot io slash
meetup dash questions
but another one was
from marcus uh
are there package license considerations
you had to think about when monetizing
shiny applications
yes definitely not all our packages are
available for free and you need to have
a license think about high charter for
example that requires an enterprise
license um
you need to be aware of that yeah
definitely
okay cool thank you
someone else tell us do you find rhino
more easy to handle reactives
so for example passing them between
modules then gollum
interesting question and i have to say
because it's a super new package i
didn't have the time to go fully into it
yet
i just kind of played around with the
toy example so i
can't really answer that question at
this point in time i hope it will be
easier because i do see some advantages
of using box
for modules compared to shiny modules
because they just
work very differently
so yeah i'm very curious to explore it
myself too
awesome i'm going to copy the questions
over from slido to the chat too just so
we have the timestamp of them
when we go back to the recording but
do you use promises to scale the
application
um no
we didn't use promises but we are using
caller instead because promises um
still wasn't providing us with with the
good solution to do whatever we want
then we found color more easy to use and
also more clean it cleans itself up
pretty easily while sometimes with
promises
some stuff lingers around to keep keeps
lingering around um and we didn't find
those issues with color so that's why we
use that instead but it works the same
as a promise uh color is nothing more
or less
except for a couple of benefits or maybe
disadvantages compared to promises so
yeah
i hope that answers that
great thank you sorry i'm just firing
this away at you right now
someone else was interested in in rhino
and said for beginners with shiny would
you recommend golem or rhino
oh that's a good question
um
i don't know for for beginners i'm i'm
actually tempted to say rhino
um
i don't know why but i i do have a
feeling that
it's especially with the documentation
they provided it could be really
a cool way to to set up your project and
for me when i was looking at rhino it
felt more
intuitively
intuitively um compared to golem like if
you have built our packages before
then i definitely think golem would be
like a good first step because it sounds
very familiar then to you um but if you
don't have experience with package
building maybe i would say pick rhino
and see what you can make of it a little
disclaimer rhino is still like super new
and in development so also the
developers say there might be some um
yeah glitches here and there obviously
um
teething issues so um
that's just a little disclaimer but yeah
i would maybe say rhino
awesome
um another question that's just being
upvoted right now from david is
the myth is that only python can be used
for production uh great apps what made
you choose to use r was it shiny
um i i chose art like in university
becca's data scientist i learned two
programming languages r and python
obviously and i stuck with r because we
i was mainly active in the
pharmaceutical industry and r is there
just um
it's more preferred above python
probably because it's
from where it's coming from
um i think it's definitely a myth that
only python can be used for production
great apps
look the language doesn't really matter
um
as as i said we we build a plumber api
using r which is just r we build an
outstanding api that is being used in
production pipelines for other companies
right now and nobody knows and nobody
really cares
what what people care about is okay an
api needs to be quick it needs to be
delivered what what i wanted to do like
maybe the data and whether it's written
in r byte and javascript node they don't
really care it just needs to be um up to
standards and you can achieve that with
r as well and obviously it's nice that
because of my new r are
that they were shiny so it wasn't like
uh
the step was was more easy to make to
build a shiny application um i learned
a few and note like later on in my
career after shiny
but i must say they're still even though
i have seen fewer nodes
i still um
we're still using shiny for enterprise
great
enterprise great apps just because um
there's a fast development
it's fast to develop extra features for
the app
and the performance is just really good
as long as you know how to use it and
how to design it and that's why i said
at the beginning
some people said to me oh your app
doesn't look like a shiny app yeah but
like we build an app
how we build it should be
irrelevant and we did that with chinese
so yeah definitely admit that i'm i'm
ready to buffs
i love it um someone also asks is
feather strictly better than using json
or what are the drawbacks
it is strictly better well i'm
kind of uh i don't think you can always
say it's 100 better in some use cases
i'm sure it will be better than the
other um for one thing feather not
everybody knows how to to deal with that
so
in our api as well we've given our users
the option which output format do you
want to have returned do you want to
have json or do you want to have feather
because
if our clients it also depends on their
end can they read in feather files do
they have tools with that
and are they comfortable working with it
etc but it doesn't really uh
it's not really different it's just data
that you are transforming a transforming
geez transferring it's just data that
you are transferring um
and and then you need to unpack it and
uh we've seen like especially uh file
sales reduction and speed reading it in
and in our case that was better
um
so yeah
that's all i can say about it
thank you
um i know we originally scheduled to
15 minutes past the hour so i want to
see if you have time for a few more
questions
yeah
okay
awesome there is a great question
i see that came in on slido was
where do you see the line between bi and
shiny for your use cases
um what positives and or limitations
would you say about both
so just to clarify what what meant with
bi like tools like power bi and stuff
yeah so i'm assuming like business
intelligence tools like tableau and
power bi
yeah okay
um
luke if you want to build
a simple standard dashboard with
standard graphs and tables
why not use power bi if you have access
to the tool and your team kind of knows
it
but as soon as you want to do custom
things
you want to have a special graph you
want to have special functionality i
mean we wanted to have a favorite devs
and so the people could actually select
their favorite products and then that
was being stored it's being stored in
the database and then the pickers kind
of they can make a choice do you want to
see only your favorites do you want to
see everything how are you going to do
that in in power bi um obviously
if you want you can do everything
probably um but then for this level of
customization i would say shiny so as
soon as you
are looking at more customized features
building things your own way especially
if you know how to leverage shiny with
custom javascript and
stuff then sky is the limit and i would
not choose for a standard um in my eyes
a standard power bi dashboard
um
and it's like because it's a web app
a chinese web app people can access it
from wherever they are whether they have
access to power bi uh yes or not
um so it's um that's good
and like positives and limitations um
yeah i think i i covered that
yeah
awesome
[Music]
um one other question was any tips
advice or resources for enterprise grade
ui development so interested to hear how
you make an app look less like a shiny
app
yeah good question um like we have uh ux
designers who occasionally design stuff
for us and then we just build it um
what we did in some occasions was
building uh html tools ourselves so with
the html widget package we built an own
widget that kind of was a
multi-page form
so we kind of we kind of built if
there's not a user interface components
available in
in anything open source we just built it
ourselves
but
one package that greatly helps to
instantly make your app look better in a
split second
bf4 dash
be it for dash it's awesome um it's a
bootstrap-based package
and bs4 dash basically turns your app
within a matter of seconds into a
good-looking app already and then
obviously you need to take care of like
placement of stuff how you're going to
display your graphs etc but ps4 dash um
already gives you like the basic layout
for a great app including like these
little nice tools that you want to have
like a dark mode light mode um
interactive components a sidebar that
kind of um
it goes away nicely etc maximizing full
screen uh mobile friendly um so yeah
definitely
indeed that
beautiful guess we should
i just put in well
in the chat too
um yeah
okay let me just see i'll go through
just a few more questions here
um but someone asked anonymously have
you found a practical upper limit for
users of a shiny app above which
performance suffers
so is there like a certain number of
users you've seen
i don't
think i've seen it like practically um
we have like i think
70 users but they're never accessing um
the content at the same time
um so i didn't experience those settings
and but i i actually can kind of
calculate how much we can handle because
we have one server which is our studio
connect and because we only allow one
connection per session um i kind of can
calculate how many sessions we can
actually have and i think the kind of
amount of simultaneous sessions we can
have is like 50 or something um
and we have five running for each of our
main apps so five for uh the api
from the cloud data farming analytics so
15. so we have still an abundance of
sessions that still can be used as spun
up without us burning into problems and
if you do run into problems it's not
like something breaks or explodes
no your user just gets a friendly
comeback later or overloaded message
so so even that is not the end of the
world you want to prevent it but yeah
but it really depends on what machinery
you put behind it the bigger your
machines
the more servers
yeah the more it can handle
awesome i've just shared one in the chat
which originally just came to mind um
it's the
california state coma dashboard i know
had thousands of users it was open to
millions of citizens so there's a blog
post on that one too
um okay let me go back over
vikram asks you recommended caching or
pins to speed up apps using data that
doesn't change often
any tips for more dynamic data
so dynamic data um
well maybe one tip i can give you if
you're talking about dynamic data you're
also pulling us from a database um
like especially since we're a startup
company we basically
just started somewhere you know we had a
database which was fine as soon as we
started looking into optimizing the
database as well
changing the number of cores changing
the availability there
massive gains
so if you can pull data from a database
and your database is faster and
organized well
because organization matters where do
you put your indexes how are you going
to make sure that um data can easily be
retrieved
um
then i would definitely look into that
it's just
whenever you're developing an app and
you need to pull in data you always have
to ask yourself
do i really need everything of this data
um
if not can i make it smaller and where
does this data come from and can i make
wherever it came from faster yes or no
so yeah
thank you
um so let's take time for two more
questions and if there's anything else
um that we missed if it's okay if i send
them over to you
and maybe we can answer them through
email okay cool
i see
leonard just asked uh thanks for a great
presentation and meetup if you have time
was wondering if you have shiny canon
installed on the development machine or
on a server
so we have it installed on our linux
ubuntu server
yeah
okay so is that a developer well yeah we
have two servers one development server
one production server i think this one
was installed on our development linux
server yep
cool thank you
and then i see mara asked
i want to know if you could share some
of the script testing of the shiny
project in the presentation
but also and thank you for this webinar
i don't know if you're like are you able
to share any of this with the recording
uh yeah well i have actually here um
this is my stain let's sing touchlight
um
go find me on linkedin um i have here a
bunch of resources of the things that i
mentioned i'm not sure if you mentioned
if that
answered your question um i can also
share my gift of username in the chat or
rachel can do that um
yeah i can actually i can't chat can i
chat well i'm host i'm inside you you
can as co-host yep
yeah so this is my my github username um
i have a couple of uh gifts on there and
open projects which
well
go over some of these topics for example
there are examples with color there
there are examples with shiny options
there
with using tables et cetera probably you
can find some code there
yeah
awesome yeah i'll share these slides and
then the links to all the resources with
the recording which we'll put up on
youtube and then i'll share it on
linkedin and twitter or wherever i
posted
the meetup as well
yeah perfectly fine
awesome i just want to say thank you so
much viola for an amazing presentation i
see a ton of great feedback coming
through on slido too because we're not
using the chat
but a bunch of people saying this has
been an excellent presentation and i
really appreciate it
oh thank you that's really nice to hear
yeah thank you all for joining and um
yeah let's stay in touch if you have any
questions you can reach out here to
rachel and
yeah thank you
thanks for the invite
yeah definitely thank you so much have a
great rest of the day everybody
bye everyone
[Music]
you